the prime minister approaching the end
of the road out of lockdown
but with case numbers climbing rapidly
even as restrictions are lifted
questions over whether he's really got
this under control
the prime minister let the delta or we
can call it the johnson variant
into the country and let's be clear
let's be clear
why the number of cases will surge so
quickly
because he is taking all protections off
in one go that
is reckless and high infection rates not
just a problem for those who catch covid
if there are a hundred thousand
infections a day that means hundreds of
thousands perhaps
millions of people are going to be
pinged to isolate
but the pm has no intention of slowing
down convinced vaccines will flatten
bumps in the road
what we will be doing is moving away
from self-isolation
uh towards uh testing in the course of
the next
few weeks and that is the prudent
approach because we all have mr speaker
vaccinated even more people the leader
of the opposition not the only one with
concerns a committee of senior mps
also testing the pm's plan how many
contacts
we'll have to isolate during that extra
28 days
i haven't seen any any any data on that
and
obviously it will depend on uh on the
numbers over the course of that
28 days the extra days that have been
imposed
that's over five million people we've
been looking at all the
uh the data and trying to strike the
right balance
i know you've said on many occasions you
don't actually have the data
which is quite concerning we're already
seeing businesses
unable to function and hospitality
businesses having to close
we have to make sure that we
use the tools we have to in the form of
isolation
to get through this particular phase it
won't last long
boris johnson's betting that he can pass
through the peak of a third coved wave
in the summer months with the vaccine
rollout
giving him enough political protection
to press on
but it is a gamble the link between
cases hospitalizations and deaths may be
weakened
but it hasn't been completely broken
while the unfettered circulation
of the virus raises the risk of new
variants
and that's why sarkirstama thinks that
the surging virus
will force the pm into reverse
the prime minister taking a hands-off
approach but
even as he projects confidence how this
next phase of covert plays out
still very much up in the air beth rigby
sky news